Welcome to the last lesson. Here, we're going to return to
a data set that we've talked about several times before, the open
street map data set, and we're going to make a case study
out of it. There are several reasons why we chose to use
this data set for the case study. First is that it's
a really nice data set, freely available for download, and it's XML,
which is a data format we've gained some experience with During this
course, now this is a human edited data set. So for our
purposes this is great because there are a lot of
opportunities for cleaning. And it's relatable. You can download the
data for your own city block, your favorite summer travel
destination or a place you want to visit someday. And finally,
it's open source. Anyone can contribute to this data set.
And you can potentially submit back the improvements you made.
As you work through this case study. Just an option.
Now, the exercises we'll use the data set that I chose,
of a city that I know very well, Chicago. Now
we're going to grade the submissions according to this data set,
but please bear in mind that there might be cultural
differences in how, for example, phone numbers or addresses. Are formatted.
What makes sense in Chicago might not make sense in,
say, Kobe. So, if you want to take your improvements
back to the community that created the map, you should
take local specifics into account. Okay. Good luck, and have fun.